شيله ريال مسميات اطلقها المصريون في على
عملات الخمسه قروش والعشره قروش والعشرين
قرشا في السابق ليس في زمن بعيد في
ثمانينات وتسعينات كان يمكن ان تشتري
بيضات اكياس من المقرمشات او تشتري هذه
العملات
كانت مصروفا يوميا بكثير من طلاب المدارس
في تلك المرحله اليوم عفا الزمن على تلك
العملات لكنها اكتسبت قيمه جديده القدام
والتاريخ
رفعت سعرها الى الاف جنيهات الاستثمار في
هذه العملات هو سوق ضخم في مصر حاليا تباع
في المزادات وعبر الانترنت بمبالغ خياليه
بسبب قيمتها التاريخيه وبالطبع حاله
الاستاذ مصاحبه للفتره التي تمثلها
وذكريات الطفوله
[موسيقى]
جنيه وهذا نصف جنيه وهذا ربع جنيه كانت
هذه العملات تمثل مصروف المدرسه منذ بضع
سنوات كنت اذهب الى المدرسه فرحا لشراء
الفطور به فالجنيه كان كافيا لشراء قطعتين
كيك وعلبه عصير تفاح المفضله لديك
[موسيقى]
لم تمر الكثير من الاعوام لارى اليوم
مصروف المدرسي يباع في البازارات كعمله
تذكاريه قديمه باضعف ثمنه ومازلت في
العشرينات من عمري
النصف جنيه والربع جنيه والخمسه قروش
والعشره قروش التي كانت المصروفه المدرسيه
اليومي للاطفال من جيل الثمانينات
وتسعينات تباع حاليا في حافظه البلاستيكيه
بمبالغ تتراوحو ما بين 65 و 70 جنيها
[موسيقى]
ولكن ليس هذا وحده العجيب فنحن نرى كل
طفولتنا اليوم يراها اشقاءنا الصغار تراثا
في افلام كرتون سابق ولاحق والمغامرون
الخمسه ولعبه الاتاري وشرائط الكاسيت
اصبحت ايضا قديمه وتذكاريه كما ربع جنيه
وانت ماذا اصبح تذكاريا من طفولتك
من القاهره ينضم لنا جامع العملات حسام
الجندي اهلا بك يا حسام هلا كانت تشرح لنا
لماذا العملات القديمه النقديه باتت تباع
اليوم بالضعف ثمنها
الفكره كلها ان الناس كلها بدات تجمع
العملات
شايفين اشكال مختلفه يعني مثلا فئه نصف
جنيه عندنا
واحد
تمام
[موسيقى]
احنا معاك يا حسام
الفكره كلها اني مثلا
بعد قيامه الجمهوريه العربيه
كان في عندنا نصف جنيه ده اللي هو بيبدا
مثلا من سنه 60 بعديها بيجي فتره
السبعينات في عندنا مثلا نص جنيه ده
ده فتره السادات بعد كده بنيجي لفتره
الثمانينات
بيبقى معنا الشكل ده وبعد كده الشكل ده
فده خلى الناس تشوف ان في اختلاف في
العملات
الفتره اللي فاتت شوفنا كثير قوي الناس
بقت بتجمع عملات اكثر بسبب ظهور برده
للعملات الفضيه في مناسبات كثير قوي
فالناس حبه تجمع كل المناسبات ديه
حسام بس خلينا نفهم الام بيصير يعني هلا
العملات القديمه هي بطل الناس يستخدموها
ويتداولوها فبالتالي صار يبيعوها كالسكار
اه طبعا هي حاجه ملغيه لكن متداوله عندنا
يعني مثلا كمان في عملات بتبقى تذكاريه زي
العملات ديت همم دي مثلا مناسبه صلاح
الدين الايوبي
اه اوكي في مناسبه لام كلثوم
للمكتبه الاسكندريه
وكم يبلغ ثمنها هلا يعني بعض العملات اللي
عندك
الفكره كلها جاءت لي لما شفت في اختلاف
يعني انا كان فتره بتاعتي المفروض نصف
جنيه ده
لما لقيت في يدي النص جنيه ده لا في
اختلاف فسالت والدي قال لك في اختلاف همم
في قبل كده كمان في اشكال كثير كمان دخلت
في الفضه في طقم النادي الاهلي مثلا حببني
اكثر في طقم الشيخ الشعراوي الحاجات ديت
كلها خلاص
تذكرات تجمعها
انا لو عندي زياده باشوف حد من زمايلي
اللي ما عندوش مثلا قطع ديت بديها له واخذ
قطعه من عندي
انا شايف ان هو ده افضل حل يعني الفكره بس
عندنا في مصر شويه ان احنا ما عندناش
ثقافه التبادل وكده
ما فيش معارض ما فيش حاجات من ديت احنا
بنشكرك جزيل الشكر من القاهره جامع
العملات حسام الجندي